jarre vespière bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france pour parler de
cette rencontre aujourd'hui attendue à
genève entre anthony blinken et sergueï
lavrov qu'est ce qu'on peut en attendre
quelle sera la teneur des échanges
écoutez on est dans une situation
doublement difficile parce que la russie
demande des concessions sur la position
jeu politique de l'ukraine sans vouloir
parler avec l'ukraine donc ça c'est
quand même une difficulté et en voulant
parler exclusivement à avec washington
bon ce qui est positif pour son image de
puissance et de l'autre côté ben
washington ne peut pas faire grand chose
puisque
n'est ce pas dans la constitution
ukrainienne est depuis la fin de l'année
2020 il y a l'objectif d'intérêt à
l'otan donc on est dans une situation a
donc deux d'échangé de dialogue entre
washington et moscou mais il manque le
cren au milieu donc c'est une difficulté
et de l'autre côté et bien washington
doit prendre le pouls et échanger avec
l'ensemble de ses partenaires de l'otan
puisqu'il ya quand même 29 pays l'otan
c'est
925 millions de citoyens vivant dans un
régime démocratique dont vous voyez vous
les choses ne sont pas simples et je
crois que là aujourd'hui et bien il n'y
aura pas de proposition concrète
certainement de pouvoir se revoir dans
une échéance de quelques jours ou de
quelques semaines mais il ya aussi un
autre paramètre qui est l'économie russe
qui pâtit de cette situation la bourse
de moscou a perdu plus de 22% depuis le
mois de novembre alors vous le disiez
pas de résolution diplomatique
attendus aujourd'hui quels sont les
scénarios possibles dans les jours qui
viennent est ce que on peut s'attendre à
une escalade encore entre les deux
nations il peut y avoir une augmentation
des tensions de coûter militaires
d'avoir comme disait militaire
d'ailleurs une gesticulation c'est ce
que moscou se préparent à faire avec
l'envoi de forces navales dans en mers
et océans du monde donc il y a une
position si vous voulez acquirent joie
plus la psychologie que la dissuasion
parce que n'y a rien de la crainte de
manoeuvre russe dans l'océan atlantique
mais a vis-à-vis dossier ukrainien il ya
donc des positions d' influence un mec
qui ne modifie en rien les éléments du
problème ukrainien alors si on peut
aussi ukrainien anthony blinken a dit
parler d'une seule voix au nom des états
unis aux noms ses alliés aussi néanmoins
ce qu'il ya des divergences sur la
posture américaines chez les alliés
américains a vraiment cette fois ci on a
dit que il ya quelques temps
l'otan était en mort cérébrale n'est ce
pas eh bien je crois que le fait de deux
exercé une contrainte sur les alliés de
l'otan fait en sorte que l'ensemble de
ces pays bien après une position
pratiquement identique sur le dossier
ukrainien donc une solidarité de
l'estonie à à l'italie et de
l'angleterre à la france on est tous
unanimes sur effectivement la difficulté
de ce dossier et de pouvoir résoudre
cette difficulté dans le temps et le
temps n'est pas forcément un allié pour
la russie c'est ça qui moi m'a tirosh
beaucoup il y a culte et
pour quelle raison le temps n'est pas un
allié pour la russie comme vous venez de
venir et bien sur le plan économique
voyez vous comme je le précisais la
bourse de moscou a perdu 22% depuis le
mois de novembre depuis le début des
nanas des manoeuvres militaires ce qui
est énorme le rouble n'est pas du tout
en bonne position à nous qui avons en
europe et dans beaucoup de pays
développés à les etats-unis le japon des
taux bancaires à autour de 0% au niveau
des banques centrales est bien le taux
de la banque centrale russe et à 8,5
pour cent parce que l'inflation est à
10% donc la situation économique russe
est difficile le seul avantage de cette
tension militaire et diplomatique ce
qu'elle maintient le prix du pétrole un
peu plus élevé parce que les marchés ont
peur donc voilà il y a des revenus un
peu supérieurs certainement par rapport
à ce qu'il devrait être au niveau des
matières premières des exportations de
matières premières russes donc ça c'est
un point positif mais sur l'ensemble du
dispositif économique russe la situation
est difficile merci beaucoup j'ai un
vestiaire pour votre éclairage ce matin
sur rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
fondateurs du web magazine le monde
décrypté